How do we do this when we have 40 billion things going on?
You need to prioritize, bro.
Kenny, look at all the stuff you gotta do.
Cause I know you got a job, I know you got kids,
I know you got everything.
What is the one thing that would move the needle
towards your goal?
First of all, you gotta have your goals, right?
And I know you do.
So you got your goals, and if your goal is 20K,
what's the one thing you could do today
that would get you closer to the goal?
Go get a sale, okay?
Is there something you need to do before
you can go get a sale?
You gotta hook the business owner, cool.
Go hook the business owner, yes.
When you have 40 billion things going on,
what's the one thing that's gonna get you
closer to the goal?
It's by getting a damn client, okay?
Go get a client.